captain sir tom moore was a hero  in the truest sense of the word in the  dark days of the second world war  he fought for freedom and in the face of  this country's  deepest post-war crisis he united us all  he cheered us all up and he embodied the  triumph  of the human spirit it's quite  astonishing that at the age of 100  he raised more than 32 million pounds  for the nhs  on his own and so gave countless  others their own chance to thank the  extraordinary men and women  who have protected us throughout this  pandemic  he became not just a national  inspiration  but a beacon of hope for the world our  thoughts  today are with his daughter hannah and  all his family  and his legacy will long live after  you